premiers flocons et déjà quelques
skieurs s'élancent sur les sentiers mais
pour acheter l'équipement plusieurs
n'ont pas attendu que la neige recouvre
le gazon dans cette boutique de laval la
vente de ski de fond est en forte hausse
depuis le mois de septembre où l'on ne
dit même mettre des petits meubles pour
décorer notre main parce qu'on est plus
qui les scripts courses classiques y en
a presque plus en 60 ans d'existence
chez andré jack sport c'est de loin
l'année de tous les records jamais vu ça
c'est meme popol auch d'une saison autre
record de tous les temps là c'est co2 de
ces augmentations monstrueuse
car pour des dizaines de clients c'est
un retour au ski de fond je faisais que
ces petits jeux nouveau cette année
c'est la même chose que le verrou dans
le fond tu sais c'est des sports c'est
plus facile de distanciation mêlée ce
qu'ils font les gens se voyait seul sur
la piste nous très distants les uns des
autres
pas que je pense que ce qu'ils font est
un petit peu associé un peu comme le
vélo que moyen de te retirer
et puis d'être moins entouré d'autres
d'une masse de gens l'engouement est tel
que le gérant a dû rappeler ces
fournisseurs et faire de nouvelles
commandes
on était rendu au 5 septembre que les
commandes en indiquant bien on va se
parler on a besoin de beaucoup plus de
matériel mais comme des quantités hors
de l'ordinaire
attendez vous donc à croiser bien des
skieurs sur les pistes cet hiver ici
vincent maisonneuve radio-canada laval